hello everyone and welcome to another
fun game from the world blitz
championship we still have like uh a
week uh before the start of the tata
still chess tournament so if you guys
have any of your own favorites from the
world rapid and blitz do use hashtag
suggestion i will do my best to cover
them uh so it's a daniel dubo versus
alireza furuja uh
it's always enjoyable watching games by
either of them but when they play
together uh that's always uh a treat and
this game it's like uh
there's one moment in the game where you
have to do something but you don't and
then just everything falls apart so uh
let's check it out uh duplo with the
white pieces opens with d4
we have knight to f6 knight to f3 g6 we
have g3 and bishop to g7 both players
fiance their darks uh their
king side bishops uh we have castles uh
and castles we have d6 and now a4 it's a
bit uh
well more standard to go see for here
but a4 is not uh not an unknown idea you
want to grab more space on the queen
side uh we have knight beat to d7 and a5
we have c6 now uh and b3 and here yeah
there are some games where queen to c7
was played but uh alireza plays queen
he plays e5 and it is now as of move a
that we have a completely new game
so let's see how dubo deals with as he
captures on e5 we have d captures and
now knight f to d2 he wants to play e4
but he also needs some support for that
e4 square so alireza plays e for himself
he doesn't allow it and it seems like
he's giving up a pawn but not really as
well if you play knight captures an e4
knight captures and then the rook is
hanging as well so uh this is uh the
moment that i've mentioned before the
game started it's that one little moment
where you have to play rook to a2 you
just move the rook out of the way and
then the game continues and then you
know no problems uh maybe gets to play
e3 he messes up a dubose spawn structure
but uh well well he's down a pawn uh but
dubo played knight to c4 instead and he
doesn't care about this bishop being
able to attack the rook and so
alireza goes for it he plays knights to
d5 first uh we have now an attack on the
rook here rook to a4 and now knight to
c5 going after the rook and now rogue
goes back all the way to a2 uh where he
uh well
should have been placed
from the start so knight's the b4 again
attacking the rook here and now what do
you play here uh it's uh well it's hard
to say if you play rook to a3 then we
simply capture the queen queen captures
and see one rook captures and knight
captures on c2 again attacking the rook
uh white's entire position just falls
apart so adobo instead decides to give
up the exchange he plays a bishop to a3
we have queen capture sunday one rook
captures and now knight captures an a2
uh we have bishop captures on c5 and now
rook to e8 guarding that e for pawn uh
but just the bishop captures an e4
because if the bishop is captured then
you're going to play rook to d8 check
and well only move his bishop to f8 uh
if you if you don't want to give up the
rook and after bishop captures it would
be completely winning for white all
sorts of nasty discoveries like bishop
to h6 checkmate is being threatened so
very very tough for black but instead
after bishop captures an e4 of course
alireza played bishop to h3 now the
rooks are connected the other rook is
ready to get into the game bishop to g2
and now bishop to g4 even though alireza
could just trade and pick up the e2 pawn
he plays bishop to g4 first
we have a6 and now b6 chasing away the
dark square bishop bishop back to e3 and
now bishop captures an a2 uh we have
rook to d2 attacking the bishop and
bishop captures on c for now we have b
captures on c4 and rook a to c8
we have c3 uh trying to keep this knight
here if uh if this type can be captured
then obviously that's going to be very
good so knight captures in c3 and black
has a way out knight captures and the
bishop captures on c3 attacking the rook
and rook to d7 so this is the position
uh for his sacrificed exchange dubo has
the bishop pair and he has a very active
rook on d7 going after that a7 pawn uh
but uh it it's not going to be easy
alireza plays rook c to d8 he gives up
the a7 pawn which could be dangerous the
a6 pawn now becomes a past pawn
uh but rook to d1 check
bishop to f1 and not rook to a1 we have
to put our rook behind the passport as
well king to g2 now the bishop can come
back into play and now c5 so we don't
have to worry about this bishop here
bishop to d3 and now rook to a2 now
threatening rook captures on uh e3 as
the f2 pawn is pinned so king to f3 and
now the ship to d4 of course all it is
that wants to trade down as much as
possible as he's up material so bishop
captures we have c captures and now
bishop to e4 by do both a very tricky
move uh
guarding the a8 square so if this pawn
ever comes to a7 then white has nothing
to worry about but it's not going to be
easy to get the rook away from here as
soon as you move the rook uh the a6 pawn
will fall but this also means that black
will have to keep the rook on a2 for a
very long time uh but uh
just to give you an example it's it's
very easy for black to
make some sort of a mistake here for
example if f5 we can just play bishop to
d5 check and now our rook and bishop
combo is excellent here also you could
bring the king over to h6 for example
king h8 now even c5 you you attack the
rook and also the b6 pawn so there are
there are some ideas here uh but um
alireza has to make some sort of a
faulty move in a better position of
course he doesn't he just plays rook to
a3 check
now he wants to get the king away from
the defense of the bishop and hopefully
win it king to f4 and now he plays uh
well he plays d3 he starts advancing his
own pass pawn even though g5
is just deadly now i'm gonna show it but
it's a three minute blizz game so of
course you can see everything rook to a5
uh sorry rook day five check uh and
that's it you have to move the king away
from the defense of the bishop uh sorry
my interface is uh
is some
is uh
uh messing around so i just have to
rewind this real quick
uh so yeah
after this uh king to f4 move uh he
didn't go for this um g5 check instead
he went for d3 and now okay now we have
uh bishop to d5 uh also maybe maybe
interesting was rook to d7 uh but still
g5 is just very strong uh
after king to f5 we're gonna play rook
to a5 check but now you can play bishop
to d5 as the rook on d7 guards the
bishop so maybe this was one way to do
it uh as white would have some counter
play if black doesn't play perfectly for
example if d2 you want to bring a queen
into the game you can play king f6 and
already white is seeing some counter
play for example queen d1 you can
capture with the bishop and pick up the
queen
white is now okay
but okay bishop to d5 was played now we
have d2 now the pass pawn is unstoppable
bishop captures on f7 king to f8 and now
bishop to d5 preparing rook to f7 check
which will force the king into a
windmill uh but alireza says you have
your fun i'm just going to bring the
queen into the game so rook to f7 check
king to g8 uh we've reached the position
from the thumbnail and now uh wherever
the rook moves it's going to be checked
from the bishop so can white make some
sort of uh
some sort of at least a perpetual if not
win some material uh well there aren't
all that many options here duval played
rook to e7 check he's now ready to pick
up the rook and of course if king to f8
we just repeat rook f7 check it's a draw
so instead after rook d7 check all it is
i just picked that picked up the bishop
he plays a queen captures and d5 uh and
now if you capture on d5 we're just
going to capture the rook and he has two
rooks do both has none of course it
would be completely winning so instead
after this queen captures on d5 uh well
rook captures an e8 was played but now
ali has just played king to f7 and he
was in this position on move 39 that
daniel dubo resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done here he
is down a full queen
and well that's just uh very very sad
so you can see how an entire game can go
uh wrong very very quickly uh if you
don't uh you know uh they take one a
little break uh before you start
advancing your pieces in here uh after
alireza announced that he's ready to
move the knight and attack the rook
duval has to play rook a2 and then the
game continues uh so yeah it was a it
was a very very interesting uh idea and
the double tried to play actively but uh
he could not uh hold this um down the
exchange against uh uh so that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it thank you
very much uh for suggesting it that
there were too many games played at the
world blitz championship impossible to
follow all of them so do use hashtag
suggestion and i will try to check some
other uh games out
so yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed
it you still have time to enter the uh
chess connects us video uh or just
brings us together uh the the the email
is in the description below so uh as
usual every year we make one uh send me
a photo or a video of you teaching
someone how to play chess
you can write something you can just
send a photo uh
i'll give it like maybe until the start
of the tata still tournament then
after the tournament the video will
probably be made so if you guys are
still interested you know teach someone
how to play chess send me a video or a
photo
and you know
join the
joined this year's uh video uh so yeah i
would like to thank constantinos
sandra brennan and john mcnabb for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world thank
you i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day